Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day by,
did you hear the rumor they're trying to make Francis keynote jds late summer.
Oh No.
For who?
What do you think JD?
That song I thought they were trying to do.
Derek Lewis.
If Derrick Lewis gets by mark hot,
AH,
you can't kill her to soaring young black by
Derrick Lewis is talking shit about him.
He called him an error.
African booty scratcher.
Yeah,
I'll scratch Jack Lewis is my,
one of my favorite UFC fighter too because,
and a big,
not just because of his fighting style,
but also because of his Instagram page.
It's hilarious.
Derrick Lewis has the best sense.
He goes hard in there.
Hey,
Travis Browne.
You went so hard in the paint coming up to this girl.
Just,
he's hilarious.
He's a funny fucking dude,
man.
I mean,
you're funny.
Some nerve talking shit to Francis,
the fucking terminator.
He scares the shit out of me.
Oh,
he's so true.
Stories
those nights.
That too crazy.
I'm not sold on that shit.
Congruent brains.
Right for me right now.
No,
no,
no.
You're,
you're on this bullshit.
No,
no,
no.
He's on another level.
Who's he?
How's he going to beat our last games?
It's just not who he beats.
He how he beats him.
Knocks him out.
Dude.
He's so big.
You don't understand like check Congo was a bad motherfucker in his day,
but check Congo wasn't starching people the way.
God No is he did when he first burst on the scene.
People Forget.
We get on the Skype.
Pat Barry in a crazy,
wild slug fast when he was already hurt.
You know?
I mean,
that was a super impressive victory.
He's got some good and some good victory.
Congo fibroid Nelson.
Yes.
Roy Nelson knocked him the fuck out.
That's a bad example.
That's a whole week to apple.
Do you Roy?
It was just like this.
Roy.
Roy knocked out a lot of fucking right Isabella to it.
Now just do you think Roy Mitrione rematch in Belgium?
Your drone tweeted today,
hey,
how about we a fight after I get through fate or Mike,
you better focus on fate or Matt.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Hey,
real quick.
Roy,
fade or fight.
God.
Surprise.
Had on dad.
Okay.